[Musik]
es ist dann erledigt weißen wichtigkeit
oder vielleicht dauert an das beispiel
sehr schlechte bis kurze weiß nicht
[Musik]
heute kann ich es offen sagen ich hätte
nie gedacht dass theodor sie wenn sie
ihn seine geliebte carla die schlucht
jemals wieder betreten würde
[Musik]
war das glück dass er überlebte war das
vorsehung davon handelt diese geschichte
[Musik]
dies passiert durch passieren ja
wie ist es eingang zivilisieren in die
tiefe leid was ich mache das ist das ist
elitär ist bisher für ergangen ist der
grat für und auf der höhe alperose und
da natürlich wurzeln von bäumen die an
die abgeschnitten
sep 18 zentimeter im boden ist ruhig sie
und die gemüter gestern ich zwar nicht
zurück kubina nicht über leiters auftaut
und dann thurella graben unter last
plätze gott mir alles unter der fürs weg
und die mit dem material mit zum glück
ist wann steigen sie und soja neutrino
der oberfläche vor deiner seine lux
trifft wo bist du genau an der stelle
angeschlagen
die händler brauchen noch mehr haben und
ich rollt das mich so überschlagen bin
ich natürlich sofort aufgesprungen wären
kein oft kriegt sie versprochen sie auch
beide handgelenke waren gebrochen sowie
drei rückenwirbel theodor sie benzin
rutschte auf einer lawine aus grill den
hang hinunter nur wenige zentimeter vor
dem abgrund kam er zum stillstand
die weiß nur wie sorg stand an der
koppel trägt was mache ich mich selber
schmieden überzubewerten übertragbar
sein zumal behindern und aber routine
nicht über leiter software fehler
gemacht er will zum handy greifen da
realisierte es ist oben beim rucksack
denn viele schauen aber das in
sekundenbruchteilen ich muss zum handy
vozar littering und selbständigen werden
oder entweder gang oder kreieren
damit war der sieg macht ne ich weiß
doch sie weiß nicht was ja nicht groß
können bewegen so oder so dabei sind
unter sich
was ziemlich fragt mich nicht berufen da
sie dem motto still wenn du nicht ruft
dusko auf alle fälle als ich gegangen
wie annie das möge verkraften und über
menschen komme ich selbst meint annika
wir gerade in berlin und der norden
betroffen
ob der körper produziert und das
probiert den muskel aber die hände jetzt
dass sie irgendwie ich sagen das wäre ja
und denn das schlimmste nicht ob sie
zwei wochen der vorstellung dass bei und
die promoter bin ja soo übrig und richie
natürlich ziemlich sicher sowohl auf
wochen specialty mir kommt dem weg weiß
mit und der mini viele doch und toni alt
apotheken und das handy er weise wie ein
musical oder sexy für mutti und den 14
14 und eine stadt linksruck grünen tun
die richtlinie oder zugestellt
okay ich bin oft die pflege
und da sehr gut da uns war ja nicht
direkt mit dem da das aber nicht
aufgenommen sind
eine halbe stunde später wird er
gerettet es folgen operationen therapien
erste gehversuche und ständig fragt er
sich warum habe ich überlebt
[Musik]
sie schob sekundenbruchteil der wink
irgendetwas wichtiges ziemlich sicher
sehr wichtig sein als erledige ich
kandidatur vor was das wird in der tat
war die antwort krieger und ziemlich
sicher ist dass sie eine dörfer sterben
dass sie das muss ein lediger
[Musik]
zwei jahre nach seinem absturz tauchte
oder sie benzin an der mineralienbörse
in diesem teaser auf frauen die
unbekannte freuen sich dose wie sie ihn
nennen zu sehen
er scheint fast wieder der alte zu sein
passiert ist aber es ist im gebirge zu
erfahren war ist also salzstock brüchig
oder schlecht sind sie nicht schön sagte
dose benzin zu einem bekannten die nimmt
man gern heraus in berghütten sie
erkennen und er sagt von solchen
schönheiten kann man nur träumen nicht
wahr dose
wunderbare schöne sind muss man schon
sehen ein kompliment für die us-kunden
soko limitiert die mieter
ich habe freude jetzt muss nicht alles
im leben
naja da sie klare der aufräum netz.de
klare politik folgen haben ich bin
sportler oder andere sport weiß nie
[Musik]
theodor sie benzin sind tiefe wunden
geblieben bloß sieht man die nicht
der kräftige und kühne draufgänger von
einst erscheint mir heute dünnhäutiger
und ja demütigen
von cher muth haus betrachtet er immer
wieder die quadratisch lucht er will
dorthin zurück realität ist im moment
kann ich bin gerade am 16 april amerika
zurück und was natürlich in der praxis
museums setzte ein blitz mit der psyche
zu
und dass ich angst steckt natürlich und
da muss schon objektiv und vorbereiten
und für nichts erzählt wie schritt und
einfach nicht wellen erfasst das
schlechteste das nur überlebt steckt
nämlich sehr schon manchmal warum mich
und die anderen nicht aber überglücklich
so beantworten muss irgendwie muss die
realitäten akzeptieren und sich dann
kommt eines tages ein eingeschriebener
brief schlagartig sind seine guten
vorsätze in frage gestellt der ohnehin
beschwerliche weg zurück in den alltag
blockiert
die staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt gegen
ihn wegen hehlerei
vor jahren hat er an einer börse einen
kristall aus der nähert tunnel gekauft
ein strahler kollege erfuhr davon und
fand ihn bei der polizei
das corpus delicti bewahrt er im tresor
auf und zum alptransit und kaufte eine
idee 2008 den mineralientagen in münchen
es hätte gekostet haben für den 17 06 11
und jetzt natürlich noch spezifischer
oder eine plötzliche schriebe krieg
wurde staatsanwaltschaft kanton uri
wegen hehlerei und jetzt sind sie so
quasi über nacht zum dirk wolter
und dass toni natürlich akzeptiere oder
sind es mit der akzeptanz ist und somit
akzeptieren
kyoto sie benzin nimmt sich einen anwalt
während er mit seiner genesung
beschäftigt war veränderte sich einiges
im umgang mit den eher trist ahlen
seit der besten funktionäre laut gesetz
gehörten die nähert kristalle der
allgemeinheit wer sie behält kauft oder
damit handelt begeht ein offizialdelikt
im jahre 2005 hatten wir glück wir
konnten den funk einer kristall kluft
filmen
sie enthielt kleine hat das seltene und
entsprechend wertvolle piloten kristalle
doch wem gehören diese kristalle
mineralien muss ja nicht und meint ute
gfrerer das im prinzip war hat der
steirer haufe zum marktpreis oder sie
könnten sogar also dass sie schauen und
das relativ gute regelung
soweit die regelung in der praxis sei es
anders aus werden der 14 jahre lang
dauernden bauarbeiten unter sedrun
wurden so gut wie keine christal funde
gemeldet dass sie die an der front
formiert sich die mädels nicht so blöd
und müssen kristalle conwert ja nix für
mich drum mini definition ist entweder
die möglichkeit drei jahren und bei
weniger sonne auf sicherheit vom turm
mit dem ihr können das ist ja neben mir
gesagt die mineure diesem vorne an der
front und die turner und tänzer und das
ja richtig was sind wir christen vorteil
überall in europa jahrelang sah man in
der gemeinde dem ausverkauf der nähe
kristalle zu als auf einmal in der
gegend selbstwert kristalle herumgeboten
wurden schlugen die verantwortlichen zu
es gab diesen dies träfe der meinrad
präsident vor der union kristalline und
er wird heute das große problem für die
touristen vom alptransit arbeitsgerät
und analysiert wie ins kino zu schützen
dann bekommen sie sind beide duos pickt
aus der region
obwohl die mini schon lange weg sind sie
wahre glück verhindern
[Musik]
nein
meinrad gegen konnte von einem - eine
genäht kristalle kaufen und stellte sie
in diesen dieser museum in die sammlung
dabei bedachte er keine sekunde lang
dass die nachbargemeinde ist so scharf
einfahren würde ein kauf sagt ein
reittier habe der mineur erzählt die
kluft sei riesig gewesen er habe
lediglich noch einige kleine kristallen
aus nehmen können
die besten stücke seien längst weg
gewesen
selbst machen tempo im museum dass ich
gesund solches theater eingeschlossen
sind mit den aktuell fordert meint vom
vereinsvorstand und du jetzt und für die
polizei den kopf gestellt und die an der
recht druck macht vor der polizei haben
wir müssen wege vor werden dass mit ihr
steigen und das habe da nichts halten
am schluss hat den kantonspolizist
sofort den posten bekam eine busse von
1500 franken und weitere 4000 franken
bedingt auf zwei jahre
was denken sie wenn sie jetzt können es
ist ruhig ruhig hier will er den von der
union kristallin und vom museum
unterwellenborner formalia fasst sich
überhaupt das silber motto wenn wir den
bürger verrückt machen oder will man als
sie schöne alte system behalten oder
limmer die einfach spurlos verschwinden
als die fragesteller touren
was teodosic benzin besonders heftig
macht bedient haben sich alle aber nur
einige wenige müssen dafür büßen
dabei habe er doch stets allen offen für
zeile mehr stein erzählt
nun will er dafür kämpfen dass
ehrlichkeit etwas gilt vielleicht denke
ich ist das für ihn die aufgabe die er
noch zu erledigen hat der grund weshalb
berlin der kamera die schlucht am leben
blieb klar das geht natürlich nur
optisch und deren probiert das bisserl
als lächerliche york an und schwamm
drüber
ich glaube das beste wie ich verstoße
sowie das machen
ein mensch säge und etwas verteidiger
das ist nicht stimmt dann stimmt ja
nicht
und akzeptiert ohne das muss ich
akzeptieren
während die herren und die bilder
schlechter verteidiger wenn es mit rief
damit dem motto mir will ja nicht so
viele jahre zu leben ist jetzt achter in
kitzbühel im januar 69 zu rechnen wie
viele viele jahre das in ohren und die
probiere ich hoffe dass ich so sexy
erklärt an akzeptanz verteidigen aber es
ist nicht einfach aber doch probieren
wie das ankommt
ich glaube ich schenkte den kindle
faktor des events ihn doch sein anwalt
fortunato vinzens dreht ab obwohl in der
stein sicht ich glaube jetzt klären wie
das überhaupt wie die kette ist wo das
herkommt dass sie verlangen bessere wir
sind interessiert und für der herr
benzings jedoch kein problem wenn er das
einen öffentlichem sv vertreter von
kanton anwesen sie sind kauft hält zu
meiner türe brice also doch
strafrechtlich klinik problem aber dass
man vielleicht mehr user findet was ich
so alles kann
als die beiden beim staatsanwalt in
altdorf antraben müssen wissen sie
bereits durch welche hände der kinder
ging gefunden hatte ihn ein
österreichischer mit über 20 händler
gelangte er in münchen schließlich in
theodor events ins besitz unklar ist
noch kommt der stein aus oder aus
bündner fels oder anders gefragt ist er
und staatsanwalt überhaupt zuständig für
den fall
aber das ist
ja
während der befragung der beiden besuche
ich dass ordner mineralienmuseum in
seedorf von einer ausstellung wie dieser
können die bündner nur träumen der uno
mineralien auch sehr peter amacher
sammelte sie im auftrag des kantons uri
im tunnel abschnitt zwischen amsteg
umsiedlung er weiß ganz genau wo er
welche kristalle kommen
auch theos events insg windel das geht
eine nutzbare möglichkeit derzeit dem
gefährt unter null bis sechs liter und
sonder unteren goslar auf bündner wurde
und von der afrika die schöner heller
wir als cdu nie museum sind gerne und
immer schlägt demnach werde der
staatsanwalt für theo dose benzins fall
gar nicht zuständig stellung dazu nahm
er keine
noch läuft das verfahren
vivi stand
ich fühle mich schlecht muss ich sehe
also da fühlst du irgendwie wie ein
krimineller
doch kein krimineller klar so erzeugt
indem sie natürlich den innerlich finde
finde ich verletzend
als besondere highlights aber die andere
frau die diese gesellschaft stellt
wahrheit ist eine andere frage stellen
muss man lügen zum zum berühmt werden
und dazu eine erfahrung zu ziehen weiß
nicht
[Musik]
auch wenn das gezerre um den nähert
quintett adoro sie dancing belastet
nicht alles ist schwer
kurz nach der befragung gelang es ihn
wieder zu strahlen
[Musik]